[Music]
and at manipulation news ad manipulation
submitted by ice-wall Wow swallows I
wallow oh come
yep dan you won't say it at all no cuz
then they're gonna cut that letter like
yeah a company is offering men a service
that promises to convince your partner
to initiate sex oh wow wait what I
missed it a company is offering men a
service that promises to convince your
partner to initiate sex that's funny
yeah right little bit creepy that is why
can't you just talk to your lady yeah
what you have to permit your ladies not
that into you
hey I just think it's kind of crazy that
this is like a global problem like all
men feel this way you know that there's
a whole company there chicks don't want
to [ __ ] them so this company here they
call themselves the spinner and they say
that they use targeted ads that will
quote influence her on a subconscious
level to initiate sex part of the basic
package the target will be strategically
bombarded with ten articles presented
about 180 times over a three month
period and the way they do that is first
you pay $30 and then you're gonna get an
innocent-looking link to share with your
wife or girlfriend and then that
attaches a cookie to her device when she
clicks on it and then she'll be
bombarded with that dude I would break
up with my person if they did this to me
yeah if they're trying to manipulate ya
is that so manipulative and that gives
me trust issues like [ __ ] you like just
talk to me yeah exactly
so they're saying that they for these
ads they're using articles that are from
women's magazines like Cosmo and if it
has topics that say something like why
would you [ __ ] a four year old man
coming up with these legs like if I got
a link to Cosmo from Steve like
are you kidding it is for sure you think
it's a virus you're like I'm not
clicking Ali I would be like this
doesn't sound like my no but I think
what's happening is first you're saying
you're like a link to a Costco yeah like
let's say like something happened at
Costco he's like oh look read the story
and then that attaches a cookie to your
phone and then that I'd start popping up
that you're like oh I'm gonna click on
this and then that would click on that
that's so stupid
I mean men are paying $30 a month it's
not a month one thing is it successful
as it's been tested and successful let's
talk about that that's a good question I
don't know oh but yeah so like they'll
have topics that say like why women
should initiate intimacy more often and
three wait three reasons you should take
the lead and make advances on your
husband those are our topic like just go
[ __ ] your husband all these stupid
articles they're like articles that like
high schoolers read what I know I even
like the font so I'm like do it said if
I saw this I'd be like I got [ __ ] to do
what the [ __ ] popping up on your sidebar
like I would never click on that is what
I'm saying
what about clicking it's about it's
literally like seeing the subconscious
like whatever [ __ ] was that moving
intercept or no inception suction
they're trying to insect it in your mind
but we're also talking about a group of
females in this circle that we don't
really have issues in terms of
communication right like we want
something yes we want something if you
had a higher service well but that's not
fair either because you're assuming that
the person like the the man in this in
this article or whatever kind of or grew
up knowing how to properly communicate
and then on top of that probably
communicate about sex
yeah do you don't I mean no I know what
you mean and then now on the other
another partner we have that like what
if they don't know how to communicate
and they're ultra sensitive and now the
guys trying to tell them hey do you
think you might mind initiating sex this
time and then I was like whoa what what
do you mean like is that not good enough
where I just feel you know that's a very
specific situation no it's a lot of
girls I feel like that I've heard this
[ __ ] a lot but like isn't that just
something you learn from experience like
it's something that we all like you
learned like this is just straight-up
manipulation yeah I agree
I agree 100% I agree but I can see the
desperation why men are like I don't
know how to talk to my wife I don't know
how to talk to my girlfriend I don't
even know how to bring this up you know
cuz maybe they've tried in their own
stupid way and the girl took it as an
attack yeah and you know point and I
feel like a lot of times so I have read
a lot and like seen a lot of videos
where like men literally feel so
unwanted that they're like I just want
you to initiate it one time but they
don't know how to communicate that over
to their partner like some men lack the
communication skills of like a fifth
grader to talk about feelings
some women are also so used to having
the men initiate you just fall into that
deep man and then guys but for sure this
this is a sleeve yeah it is like I want
to know is it successful I want to know
like if your girl doesn't initiate do
you get your money back like what
imagine it's a hundred percent of like
successful yeah then I would want to
know that like that I'm like [ __ ] that
does work that's crazy but they should
find like something like maybe somebody
can create the same but for cleaning Oh
for like yeah you know they actually do
have that oh wow they do have other
types of packages like the message is
get your kid a dog the target is mom and
dad Wow
oh my god marriage target is the
boyfriend what kids gonna be able to
afford that
thirty dollars is a lot target is work
colleague you're trying to get your work
colleague to quit and find a new job
different packages and like I saw
another one for I guess target target is
the husband and I think it was to do
more more things that means all these
we're not the only like this is a
modern-day version of getting a witch to
cast a spell but what's craziest
marketers have been doing this and
playing with us for ever I've already
been doing it that's why the company
thing it's not that it's not an
unethical because I companies already
doing it yeah I mean it's unethical in
terms of the relationship because you
should be communicating or whatever but
like McDonald's right like they know
that like red and and and yellow that
that makes you hungry you know or like
when they put cereal for kids at the eye
level for kids to see like that's all
kind of manipulation yeah I'm all yeah
there's even like I was watching a video
the other day of like it's kind of funny
but it's like 10 reasons why you
shouldn't buy this purse right
and I was like watching it and that's
like my shades are you trying to talk
yourself I don't know he's targeting I'm
trying to talk your are you already got
the cookie on your eye like no but I was
watching it and like basically what the
girl was saying it's like maybe you want
the purse because you've seen a lot of
influencers wearing it and what
companies will do like high-end
companies they'll send it to six
influencers and of course they all pose
the same person you're like oh I follow
all of them like she looks so cute with
it like I'm gonna get it you know so
it's the same even if it's busted like a
lot of stuff that's popular right now Oh
dad shoes oh you think so
they are cute yeah on the right person
with the right design I like them I mean
I feel like bowling see yoga especially
like sometimes you have some sketch
fries looking shoes and I'm like if
that's it Skechers yeah you wouldn't
wear it yeah just said but that's how I
feel about all this a lot of designer
clothes like that's exactly how I feel
ya know they're really not cute so yeah
so this agency is saying that it's not
that unethical and I really wanted a
success rate as well I don't know that
info I think a better service would be
like okay what do you want from your
spouse and both of you guys take it kind
of like that counseling next one
it could be counseling but some people
can't afford it yeah that's all I was
gonna say this is cheaper yeah they can
take they can take a quiz we're like
what was it called
I forgot what it was called mojo or
something something yeah mojo that's
exactly what it's called yeah um and
then you just take a quiz or and then if
you don't know how to communicate at
least this quiz will kind of be like the
mediator and kind of tell you what you
guys are into or whatever yeah
explaining more about when mojo is it's
like they gives you this questionnaire
about your sex preferences and sometimes
like you might be too shy to be like oh
I actually I would like to try this
thing but it's just too weird to talk
about it so both partners take the quiz
and they only show you things that that
you have in common that it would Matt oh
is it free yeah oh I'm gonna take it
there's some stuff here I'd like don't
and telling that you ever know I will
but I just want to know what like maybe
I don't even you don't you think like
that poised on a magazine you're like oh
it's like discovery yeah like what
Starbucks drink am i you know
yeah they are really entertaining but
yeah I don't know so you're saying if
you would find out your guides
oh he be gone yeah for sure because like
then that means that we have no
communication then like I to me a
relationship is communication so if we
don't have that there's no [ __ ] point
like really yeah you're also very like
advanced in yourself you know like you
know a lot about yourself and you know
how to communicate through experience
yeah and a lot of people are in
introduced to that ever in their life
like a lot of people grow up in survival
mode so like the last thing they're
worried about is their feelings you know
and I'm not saying that these are the
kind of people that are gonna like buy
this but like I I like I also think that
I'm very self-aware
so I'm also like okay communicate with
me rather than do this [ __ ] but I could
see why this would make money you know
sure sure and a company like
confrontation yeah people like these
companies don't go [ __ ] about our
feelings or our relationships they're
like hey like get her to do whatever you
want pay $30 you know yeah that's why I
don't like it it's like it's like so
yeah it's like psychics are like witches
when you go to like awaiting your answer
I say it's like a spell yeah like a
spell like make them fall in love with
you okay I know I didn't even look at
the clock don't you guys feel like this
article's gonna make you look sideways
at the ads that you see now you're gonna
be like oh that ad says this am i
targeted yeah I think I'm so like used
to ignoring all the ads because it's so
but what's crazy is you don't realize
that they're there but your mind is
still looking at it so I story and your
subconscious that's what's scary yeah
that's true I hate it when I'm looking
at like I'll be interested in going to a
destination and then all of a sudden
it's all in my ads and I'm like stop no
what is it worse when you say something
to your friend you haven't even looked
into it and then it pops up while you're
scrolling but that's why Facebook got in
trouble for that cuz they finally camera
at analytical they like admitted it but
they still do it no like Instagram so
they say I know Alexis always listening
I think it's some sort of thing where at
least you have to check a box or
something
it's a automatically check on su and
check out
those Apple terms are scary when you
first activate your phone it's like pay
because you're like you're gonna check
yes otherwise you can't use your phone
back yeah cuz you're not gonna sit there
and read everything guys too crazy you
guys don't read it
shut up geo you can't read she's like I
have a lawyer who works at Farley yeah
there we go
a lawyer for that is it Stacey yes I'm
all like yeah she agrees let's go you
pay oh you spend your money
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]